bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández y hoy los
llevaremos a armenia comenzamos los
yazidíes son considerados uno de los
pueblos más antiguos su historia es una
crónica de persecuciones masacres y
éxodos forzosos desde sus orígenes en el
norte de irak a principios del siglo 20
ocurrió una huida masiva tras las
campañas turco otomanas contra las
minorías armenias y yazidí en el este de
turquía el último genocidio fue
perpetrado por el estado islámico en
2014 y alrededor de 100.000 yazidíes
supervivientes emigraron a armenia y se
establecieron allí el gobierno armenio
ha implementado medidas para integrar y
proteger a las minorías sin embargo en
la práctica no es así los y así es bien
en comunidades cerradas y marginales y
se dedican a actividades agrícolas
también muchas aldeas de mayorías ya
civil han quedado desiertas por
migración económica y las tierras se
están siendo expropiadas por el gobierno
armenio
hoy nos acompaña de tell bonet quien
junto a diego ibarra estuvieron en
armenia para conocer algunas historias
paulette el gracias por acompañarnos
quería comenzar preguntándote que te
llevo a trabajar en este reportaje sobre
los yazidíes siendo este un pueblo tan
desconocido
hola arminia bueno cuando una minoría es
desconocida se enfrenta a todo tipo de
vejaciones porque está fuera del radar
internacional y no recibe la suficiente
ayuda para que se puedan impedir estas
masacres esto es lo que ha ocurrido
recientemente a la minoría musulmana
rohingya ya los jazz y 10 los jazz y
díaz eran unos desconocidos hasta que el
estado islámico invadió las montañas de
sillar en 2014 y no fue hasta que el ex
presidente de eeuu barack obama llevó a
cabo una operación en las montañas de
singer para frenar las masacres contra
este pueblo que estaba fuera del radar
mediático los periodistas al principio
estábamos confundidos se decía que los
yazidíes eran una minoría musulmana suní
y que eran sufíes
que practicaban el zoroastrismo o
incluso que eran una antigua religión
cristiana todo esto me llamó la atención
captó no toda mi intención y decidí
investigar más y profundizar en este
tema que acabó siendo un libro el primer
libro escrito en español sobre el pueblo
y así vi el genocido el pueblo y así di
porque ni siquiera no encontré reseñas
que hablaban sobre sobre este pueblo que
estamos hablando de una de las
civilizaciones más antiguas de la
historia de hace 2000 años que se
estableció en el presente fértil en la
antigua mesopotamia y que es quizás la
primera religión monoteísta de la
historia el problema que han tenido los
yazidíes ha sido precisamente que aunque
sea una religión monoteísta no han
tenido un libro sagrado como es el
budismo como son los cristianos el islam
o el judaísmo y es por eso que ha sido
un pueblo tan odiado por los musulmanes
que los han confundido por infieles
seattle y por otro lado quería
preguntarte qué futuro de supervivencia
tiene esta minoría religiosa
ahora que está tan dividida tras el
genocidio en sinjar
el reciente genocidio sin ya realmente
puso esta comunidad otra vez en esa
situación de realmente sentir ese
peligro de supervivencia el pueblo yazid
y actualmente son cerca de un millón y
están pues / sabrán cómo nos un medio
millón habían antes no en irak y ahora
mismo quedan como 300 mil que ni
siquiera pueden regresar a sus tierras
no pueden regresar las indias porque sin
ya que está destruido 300.000 personas
están viviendo en los campamentos de
refugiados del kurdistán iraquí en el
norte de siria hay más de 3.000 mujeres
y niños todavía que siguen en manos del
estado islámico que fueron utilizados
como esclavas sexuales como soldados hay
más de 30.000 personas 30 millas y 10
que siguen desaparecidos que seguramente
estarán pues enterrados en fosas comunes
todo esto hizo que haya como un un
renacer no de esa identidad y así de y
bueno y han encontrado su lugar o están
intentando que armenia que es un que es
un país que les permite no poder ejercer
su religión y su cultura
el libro a ser otra vez perseguidos como
buscar un nuevo lugar donde ellos puedan
encontrar pues esa identidad y es por
eso que se han estado construyendo
templos espirituales allí un poco porque
realmente han perdido sus tierras
ancestrales de irak y es muy difícil que
puedan volver
gracias de tel aquí la historia
[Música]
suena una voz de lamento pero son
palabras de reproche por haber escuchado
a los dos ángeles que le llamaban y
haberla dejado sola tan pronto sobre la
tumba de asista moyano su viuda la sala
y la comunidad de amor recuerdan su
defensa por los derechos culturales de
los yazidíes para integrarlos en armenia
la memoria está muy am sigue presente en
su nieto jodor jajó yang que ha sido
elegido el nuevo líder de la unión
nacional y ha sido para continuar los
pasos de software
uno de los logros más importantes ha
sido el reconocimiento de la lengua y ha
sido en armenia como herramienta de
etnicidad nos ha dado una gran
oportunidad de introducir libros de
texto en lengua ya civil en las escuelas
para mantener nuestra cultura y ser
reconocidos como grupo étnico
lingüístico separado a los kurdos la
educación es la luz de nuestra comunidad
una vez aquí en armenia son la minoría
más numerosa con cerca de medio millón
de fieles que mantienen sus tradiciones
ancestrales y practican sus ritos con
libertad sin ser objeto de persecución
religiosa a 30 km de ereván la capital
de armenia el templo de los siete
arcángeles inaugurado en 2019 para
generar a malik town el angel pavorreal
la deidad central de su fe es hoy el más
grande del mundo su cúpula supera a la
mega yazid y el ancestral templo iraquí
de la lix donde según las tradiciones es
obligatorio peregrinar una vez en
navidad
este nuevo templo dedicado a malik town
busca hacer de armenia un puente de
unión espiritual y de libertad religiosa
entre los yazidíes repartidos entre los
países del cáucaso e irak después del
último genocidio en singar la comunidad
yazidí ha de estar más unida velar por
nuestra religión y cultura desde armenia
a irak
[Música]
el temor a ser aniquilados otra vez por
grupos yihadistas como el estado
islámico en irak ha hecho que la región
que ha sido rodeado de cierto ocultismo
por sus ritos como la adoración de
elementos de la naturaleza como el fuego
esté viviendo un resurgimiento
identitario en armenia con la creación
de ambos templos de culto estoy
agradecido por el apoyo de nuestra
comunidad en armenia pero al mismo
tiempo triste porque nuestros hogares en
singar están destruidos y nuestro
santuario de la lista se ha visto
amenazada todavía en construcción el
templo de riad asa está custodiado por
su esposo se ex salir ambos
supervivientes del genocidio ya siguen
edad hace seis meses que llegaron
armenia su hija hadeel tenía sólo un año
cuando escaparon de sillar y hicham
nació en los campamentos de desplazados
del kurdistán en esta pequeña habitación
junto al templo que veneran y protegen
han rehecho su vida pero no hay día en
que no piensen en tren deshará su
sagrado templo de la distinta
temo por el futuro de nuestro pueblo y
religión enseñar todos nuestros hogares
están destruidas decenas de miles de
yazidíes viven en los campamentos de
desplazados en el budista ni seria más
de tres mil mujeres y niños ya si diez
siguen en las manos de edades y otros
miles han huido a otros países han
querido deliberadamente partir de
nuestro pueblo para acabar con dos y así
la construcción de templos no ha sido
hasta ahora parte del acervo religioso
ya civil para ser providencia religioso
y así de armenia los nuevos espacios de
culto fueran sagrados santuario de la
lix y la veneración de símbolos más allá
de las sagradas reliquias aleja los días
y días de su verdadera espiritualidad
yo soy yo si hubiésemos sobrevivido a 74
genocidios nosotros mismos somos
descendientes de los refugiados del
genocidio armenio
hemos protegido nuestra religión durante
siglos gracias a nuestra fuerte fe
el templo tiene que ser nuestra casa
estar dentro de cada uno no los espacios
vinculados
tras el genocidio de su comunidad en
irak 2014 el chef prof fue elegido líder
espiritual en armenia veterana la
primera guerra de nagorno karabaj en los
90 entre armenia azerbayán ahora prepara
a su nieto bro como futuro líder
espiritual de los yazidíes enseñando la
importancia del pasado ya llevar una
vida sencilla en contacto con la
naturaleza y los frutos que da la tierra
bendecidos por su dios los yazidíes
somos gente sencilla unidos a la tierra
que creó nuestro dios los yazidíes no
tenemos el derecho de levantar nariz por
encima de los ojos de otro tenemos que
aceptar y agradecer todo lo que nos ha
dado nuestro dios somos gente de paz los
yazidíes viven en tres provincias
armenias mayoritariamente en aldeas
rurales y se dedican al campo y al
pastoreo el estado invertido poco
mejorar las carreteras de estos pueblos
que con el mal tiempo quedan
incomunicadas ahora cuatro últimos
deportes compacto nos falta un momento
en que alguien al final de la canaco
movilice antes del suceso
la aldea de zoric fronteriza con turquía
es uno de los primeros pueblos en los
que se establecieron los yazidíes
después de huir de las campañas de
limpieza étnica tomadas contra los
armenios a finales del siglo 19 y
principios del 20 desde las colinas a
donde llegaron sus antepasados damas
danés y alcalde de zorita nos cuenta con
emoción de orgullo la historia de como
su abuelo escapó del genocidio y fundó
este pueblo cuando estaban huyendo de
turquía dos de mis tíos resultaron
heridos y murieron en el camino mi
abuelo sobrevivió y se refugió en
aquellas montañas con el resto de
yazidíes que vinieron con él vivieron
durante años allí en tiendas de lona y
en los meses de frío llevando a
pastorear al ganado a otras zonas pero
mi abuelo decidió mover a toda la
comunidad a estas tierras para asentarse
y empezaron a construir sus casas antes
vivían aquí hasta 150 familias pero
ahora sólo quedan 20 las dificultades
económicas y sociales que enfrentan los
yazidíes llevan a muchos jóvenes a
migrar dejando a los mayores al cargo de
las tierras y viviendas
esta es una aldea pequeña junto a la
frontera en donde no hay grandes
oportunidades de trabajo los terrenos
para cultivar no son grandes tampoco hay
suficiente pasto para alimentar a las
ovejas y el ganado por lo que nuestros
jóvenes deciden marcharse en busca de
mejores oportunidades
a pesar de los esfuerzos de integrar la
lengua ya si bien las escuelas estatales
como parte del compromiso del gobierno
armenio con las minorías sin inversión
pública en las aldeas rurales y sus
escuelas los jaz ideas quedan atrapados
en el círculo vicioso de la pobreza lo
que provoca la exclusión social de esta
minoría
es muy importante proteger nuestra
lengua materna y la cultura yazidí pero
necesitamos más apoyos financieros
compartimos el pasado y el mismo
sufrimiento con el pueblo armenio
nuestros antepasados también fueron
víctimas de genocidio armenio y algunos
de nuestros hermanos han muerto en las
guerras de nagorno karabaj somos parte
de esta nación
en la víspera del genocidio armenio hace
ya 107 años descendientes de los
supervivientes de esta masacre de más de
un millón de armenios sirios griegos
ellas y diez rememoran con una marcha
pacífica con antorchas uno de los
episodios más oscuros de la historia
moderna de armenia creo que es el
genocidio armenio hubiera sido
reconocido a tiempo a nivel mundial
podrían haberse evitado otros genocidios
posteriores como el de nuestros hermanos
yazidíes en irak aún no es tarde no
podemos mirar a otro lado el mundo tiene
que conocer nuestro martirio
en fila trabaja como periodista en la
radio pública armenia ella es madre de
los hijos puede parecer algo normal en
nuestra sociedad pero la yazidi es una
cultura patriarcal donde la mujer debe
dedicarse plenamente a la familia en
filas tuvo que alejarse del núcleo
familiar y después de casarse con el
apoyo de su esposo poder a la
universidad se considera una excepción
pero lamentablemente no debería ser así
vivimos en comunidades cerradas en
aldeas donde las mujeres y azeríes no
nos permiten expresarnos somos
ciudadanas deberíamos tener las mismas
oportunidades que las otras mujeres en
lugar de estar marginadas desde las
organizaciones por los derechos humanos
se apela a un debate a nivel nacional
sobre los derechos de las minorías para
que no se sigan cometiendo violaciones
contra las libertades individuales y de
género armenia recuerdos de todas las
convenciones por los derechos de las
minorías pero desafortunadamente no son
una prioridad ni se implementan por
ejemplo en armenia no se protege a las
mujeres yazidíes de los matrimonios
precoces truncando su educación y su
futuro en amigos o jan es la esperanza
del cambio hacia la igualdad de las
mujeres y así 10 a diferencia su hermana
que casaron antes de los 18 años leen ha
desafiado a las tradiciones familiares
días y días y ha logrado ser la primera
mujer de su aldea seguir estudiando para
llegar a la universidad está en segundo
de sociología y es miembro del consejo
de alumnas de su facultad para las
chicas yazidíes es muy difícil no solo
después los matrimonios precoces es la
falta de autorrealización de las mujeres
debemos hacer oír nuestra voz puedo
decir que no hay ningún peligro para
nosotras de salir de las aldeas y venir
a la gran ciudad si realmente quieres
puedes hacerlo la em ha puesto su
granito de arena al empoderamiento de la
mujer ya cdy llevando a las aulas de la
escuela de donde a temas de discusión
sobre educación de las niñas de hace
días para hacer partícipes a las nuevas
generaciones sabían que el arcángel mere
dyn es el protector de la educación
pensáis que nuestros ángeles quieren que
las mujeres no estudien que no tengamos
una educación superior porque es
importante para ti karim ir a la
universidad porque quiero estudiar
derecho conocer las leyes para proteger
los derechos de la mujer y con ello
proteger también los derechos de las ya
civiles en armenia las chicas tenemos
que estudiar al igual que los chicos
armenia fue el primer país en condenar y
reconocer el genocidio del pueblo yazidí
en irak en 2014 a pesar de ello y de sus
políticas de puertas abiertas los
activistas por los derechos de las
minorías consideran que las políticas de
integración de los refugiados iraquíes y
así 10 son muy vagas
agradecemos el apoyo de armenia por
haber querido acoger a las víctimas del
genocidio yazidí pero una vez aquí los
refugiados ya sitges e iraquíes se
sienten marginalizados y atrapados en la
pobreza al hablar otra lengua no pueden
comunicarse con los otros no se les
intenta integrar así que están unos
meses y se van a otros países o vuelven
a irak
pero a veces pese a las dificultades
algunos deciden quedarse como caja la
cena y sus cinco hijos llegaron a
armenia hace dos años y medio y ahora
viven en la aldea de maiakovski en la
provincia de cota y han encontrado un
hogar los hijos de caja la estudian y
ayudan a sus padres con las labores de
pastoreo han dejado atrás años de
sufrimiento y éxodo por la guerra contra
el estado islámico
claro que he echo de menos sellar
nuestra casa pero aquí podemos vivir
tranquilos ir a la escuela todos mis
primos fueron capturados por el daes
volver me da miedo
y cajal a no puede ofrecer a su familia
más una vida humilde llena de trabajo
duro pero con la recompensa de no vivir
en peligro por el hecho de ser ya
semillas no vamos a volver no podemos
regresar nos mataron secuestraron e
hicieron esclavas a nuestras hijas y
mujeres en irak por ser yazidíes esto no
ha ocurrido con otras sectas como sus
hermanas mis dos hermanos siguen
desaparecidos también sus hijos mientras
haya integristas de la xxi nuestro
pueblo no estará a salvo
a más de mil kilómetros de su hogar
reina mira hacia el horizonte de las
montañas de armenia su historia y la de
tantos otros ya si diese en armenia
resume el destino de un pueblo marcado
por la persecución las masacres y la
emigración pero la diáspora que ha
crecido en europa ha permitido la
supervivencia de su cultura milenaria
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]